this is the remaking of america in real
time
on the basis of equity rhetoric that is
essentially unfair that is the goal
and if you don't go along with it you
will be cudgeled if you refuse to go
along with this stuff you will be
cudgelled
the media will simply lie to you okay
when i talk about the cudgeling
let's talk about the cudgeling for a
moment so over the weekend
in what has to be the most amusing turn
the you remember that alexi mccammon was
going to be the editor of of
teen vogue that great prestigious
publication teen vogue not just vogue
teen vogue well now it turns out that
one of the people who backed alexi
mccammon's ouster
a senior at t v teen vogue staffer
alexander mccammon was thrown out
because alexa mccammon when she was 17
wrote anti-asian tweets that was a
decade ago
now a senior teen vogue staffer who
backed alexis mccabe and being fired
it turns out that this lady wrote a
bunch of tweets back in 2009 2010
using the n-word christine david senior
social manager at teen vogue in 2009
wrote two tweets to a friend
identifying him as a n-i-g-g-a
and in 2010 used that word in a joke
tweet the friend appears to be white
davis david says in multiple tweets
shoes of mixed irish and filipino
heritage
so not a black person so you don't get
to use these sorts of terms right
mccammon 27 and a rising reporter at
axios have been set to take the top job
at teen vogue before her past tweets
set off a firestorm among teen vogue
staff after the atlanta shooting
left asian americans dead mccammon and
teen vogue parted ways
neither david norma kamen or teen vogue
could immediately be reached for comment
david on march 8 posted a letter on
instagram from teen vogue staff
expressing concern to cons and asked
about hiring mccammon quote in light of
her past racist and homophobic tweets
so proud of my teen vogue colleagues the
work continues davitt wrote
in the caption okay so here's the funny
part okay
after alexi mccammon got fired and many
of us on the right have defended many
people on the left from firing and
people on the right from firing because
it turns out that a
culture in which you can just uncover
anybody those old tweets and then use it
to wreck their career is an ugly and
gross culture
it's not about purity it's not about
making the world better now the left is
getting upset at canceled culture
now the left is getting upset why
because they like alexi mccammon because
alexi mccammon
is on the left so brian stelter who has
been openly leading a charge to get fox
news thrown off the air by its
distributors
now he's like you know what i don't like
this purity culture anymore oh
you you don't brian oh strange so you're
all for the purity culture when it comes
for people you don't like but when it
comes for people you do like
then all of a sudden you're upset with
the purity culture strange how this
works on the left
no one wins in the purity wars no one
wins
of course no one i know would excuse
racist tweets and almost everyone agrees
that we should strive for a more just
equal society
but these internal office battles zap
energy away from the real struggle
i mean no offense to mccammond but her
name should not be on the tips
of the media world's tongues not for
something she did at age 17.
so ultimately conde nast failed her
now the real struggle here the real
struggle is getting fox news tossed off
the air
that's the real struggle of course
making sure that
everybody that brian stelter personally
does not like is canceled
and making sure that everybody that he
does like is defended i happen to agree
with him about alexi mccammon but the
point is this he doesn't agree with him
about alexi mchemmon
right he just doesn't like the fact that
one of his friends somebody that he's
apparently friendly with or somebody who
he agrees with
just got ousted from her job and here's
the thing the cancellations will
continue until the morale improves
all it's funny folks on the right we
have real trouble understanding the left
because we keep looking for the through
line
why is it that lexi mccammon can get
fired but this davit lady probably will
not be fired from teen vogue
why is it that gina carano can get fired
for putting up
a meme that included a picture from the
holocaust but pedro pascal puts up a
picture from the holocaust
comparing american immigration policy to
the holocaust based on a picture that
was not even from america
and he's fine why where's the through
line and the answer is there is no
through line it is all about
pure use of power it is all about pure
authoritarian use of power so for
example i don't see brian stelter coming
out
and defending sharon osbourne right
sharon osborne committed the grave sin
of having said that she is friends with
piers morgan you're not allowed to do
that
this appears morgan said he didn't
believe meghan markle and you're
certainly not allowed to do that because
meghan markle
is now she's been sainted they're
actually going to they're actually going
to build shrines to meghan markle now so
piers morgan said he didn't believe
meghan markle by the way for the record
neither do i on the vast majority of
what she said
i'm i'm in no position to doubt her
personal feelings about suicide
but i don't believe that she was deeply
victimized by buckingham palace
i don't think that's a reality i think
that she is on the make
as demonstrated by that interview with
oprah because she's not a very good
actress
piers morgan said that then sharon
osborne said i'm friends with piers
morgan and he's not a racist
and now she's going to get thrown off
the talk and tiffany cross goes after
her so over the weekend
tiffany cross on msnbc starts talking
about how evil sharon
osborne is a message to
the biggity brit sharon osborne after
this read
maybe you should go read because there
are numerous books which greatly detail
how some of your ancestors
colonized raped and pillaged many parts
of this globe
and like you told cheryl don't cry we
toast those tiers and continue to do the
work that benefits all people in this
country
even those who don't always deserve it
so
cheerio chap and you're welcome
so so dismissive so derisive so sneering
but remember
she's of the woke so she can say
whatever she wants now if it turns out
she tweeted something bad in the past
she'll be defended because all of this
is just a power game it is all a power
game
all the time and when you speak of power
games it's important to note
how the media twists every story into
into this power dynamic
every story fits within this particular
box how does it fit into the narrative
of equity
and and how do we avoid by the way
reporting the real story in order to fit
the narrative of equity
everything is is it's agenda uber alice
it's agenda agenda agenda narrative
narrative and agenda that's all that
matters here which is why you saw over
the weekend a wide variety of articles
about the evils going on
in miami beach you saw a bunch of
stories about miami beach they're
shutting it down because they're afraid
of the covid
they're afraid of the virus now here's
the thing we've been hearing about death
santas
for literally months at this point like
six seven eight months going all the way
back to the summer
death santas ron desantis happens to be
the best governor in america for the
challenges he faced considering florida
is super
old and it ranks somewhere in the middle
of the pack like near california
in terms of deaths per million and all
of the stories about how tampa was going
to be the center of a hot spot
tampa was going to be just a coveted
hotspot it was a disaster it never
happened
the beaches at jacksonville is going to
be a co it never happened
spring break it's going to be a covet
never happened
so what was the real story here so the
media didn't even get the story right
now
they've they're not just getting the
angle wrong they're just getting the
story completely wrong
so the the story that you have heard
over the weekend is that there is a
panic in florida because of covet and
the miami beach had to shut down
because of the coveted risks that is not
why miami beach
shut down the reason that miami beach is
shutting down is because people are
committing crimes
there's open fist fights in the streets
of miami beach
okay we are talking about people running
running up bar tabs of two thousand
dollars and then just
running out like just taking off
okay and it just so happens by the way
that these are not spring breakers who
are down from university
this is people who are out partying end
of story
those people happen to be according to
the miami herald disproportionately
black
according to the according to the miami
herald martin vasalo reporting
after weeks of uninhibited partying on
south beach by spring breakers police
turned away throngs of people many of
them black from world famous ocean drive
with a swat truck
pepper balls and sound cannons the
tactics were intended to enforce an 8 pm
curfew announced only hours earlier on
saturday to rid the city
of what police and politicians have
described as unruly and sometimes
violent late-night crowds
the tactics appeared to have the desired
effect but the use of force to clear out
people of color from south beach alarmed
some black leaders
if miami beach has openly recoiled at
the behavior of the at times chaotic
crowds filling the city's entertainment
district every weekend
not just this weekend every weekend
some in south florida are having a
similar reaction to the way the city and
its police have handled the presence of
thousands of people of color
okay so what's the actual story there
are a lot of people of color
in south beach according to the miami
herald and they are engaging
in criminal activity resulting in a
thousand rest by the way there's plenty
of tape that is not being shown in the
mainstream media the mainstream media is
showing tapes of people milling around
they're like this is the real threat
people milling around that's not why
they put a curfew on they put a curfew
on because i've seen tape
people are at intersections twerking on
the streets and having fist fights like
that's
that's why they put a curfew on and yet
the media won't tell you that they'll
tell you about desantis not about
desantis
what the hell are you talking about
you're just lying about the situation
there
videos on social media showed miami
beach police arriving on ocean drive
saturday evening to find a massive crowd
still on the street
after the curfew kicked in
okay this is again you can see all the
videos
miami beach mayor dan gelber said the
curfew and causeway closing announced
at 4 pm saturday were aimed to prevent
violence and disorder
he described the city as a powder keg
ready to blow residents shared the
crackdown some saying they're afraid to
leave their homes
okay so um this is not i'm sorry this is
not
about covid but if you read the
headlines it's about covid
okay nowhere do the police even cite
covid as a risk
and yet the idea is that it's it's about
co this is ridiculous i'm sorry it's not
here's the headline over at drudge the
top headline right now
and from the daily beast south beach
overrun by mask-less hordes yeah that's
the big problem they're not wearing
masks not the fact they're beating the
crap out of each other and engaging in
criminal activity in miami beach
the problem is they're not wearing masks
it's absurd it's just absurd but again
it has to fit into the it has to fit
into the narrative and what's the
narrative the narrative is that black
people are being cracked down on
by the police and simultaneously
unrelated cove is a real threat
so they want the two stories
simultaneously now the the police are
being mean to black americans according
to miami herald at a time when the
country is undergoing a racial reckoning
the optics of police officers grappling
with crowds and city leaders condemning
a largely black group of visitors
has been unavoidable daniella pierre
president of the naacp's miami-dade
chapter tweeted
spring breaking while black on saturday
night she later added unacceptable to
say the least
okay so again the the problem of course
is that so two simultaneous problems one
it's all desantis because look at these
masculine people
and two it's the evil police
at no point can you say oh yeah maybe
there are a bunch of people engaged in
criminal activity in downtown and that's
requiring the police to go in because
that would cut against the exact
narrative that they're trying to fight
against
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content